بالطبع هناك ابنة دونالد ترامب،
إيفانكا، التي أرسلت بيانًا تقول فيه
إنني أحب والدي وأحب
بلدي اليوم، وأنا أشعر بالألم لكليهما، وأنا
أقدر الأصوات عبر
الطيف السياسي التي تعبر عن الدعم
والقلق، ماذا تفترض أن هذا
يفعل لـ  عائلة ترامب
ولكنني أتوقع بغض النظر عن مدى أهمية
الأسرة التي نتحدث عنها، أن الأسرة
ستجتمع معًا في وقت مثل هذا،
وأفترض بعد ذلك أن الأطفال سيرغبون
في الدفاع عن والدهم أو أمهم إذا
كانت في وضع مماثل، لذلك
أتوقع  إن الاستجابات الطبيعية لذلك
هي احتضان والديك
وتذكر في نظامنا أنك بريء
حتى تثبت إدانتك، لذلك نحن
الغرباء ولسنا أعضاء في
العائلة، علينا أن ننتظر حتى
تنتهي العملية و  أعتقد أن أولئك الذين هم من داخل
العائلة يجب عليهم
بوضوح أن يتجمعوا لدعم
الرئيس السابق،
شكرًا لكم